bonjour et bienvenue sur des modèles tv
pour suivre ces quarts de finale du
championnat du monde 2015 quart de
finale bien sans âme harry sebag qui
donc s'est fait éliminer en huitièmes de
finale comme on a pu le voir
malheureusement mais on a quand même
deux gros matches à suivre avec un pic
au déroule indienne qui va jouer face à
mariam ou zouk
on a aussi arabisé la géorgienne qui
jouera face à arica une autre et nien
donc deux indiennes et qui tenteront de
se retrouver un puisque si elle gagne
vont jouer en demi finale et les deux
autres quarts de finale c'est bien
entendu
natalia pogo nina donc qui a battu mary
ces vagues qui va jouer face à la
chinoise
sunao qui elle aussi avec un pic au
nehru fait partie des deux favorites et
enfin un dernier quart de finale
surprenant alors pas parce qu'on va y
retrouver pia cramer ling qui a
cinquante deux ans maintenant fait
partie quand même de la légende du jeu
d'échecs et démontre qu'elle est
toujours au top niveau mondial
et puis bien et surtout qu'elle va jouer
face à en fait une deuxième music uk oui
deux ukrainiennes et qui porte le même
nom et pourquoi parce que ce sont deux
soeurs un amouzou qu qui a deux ans de
moins que sa soeur maria
donc on se retrouve avec deux soeurs en
quarts de finale donc de ce championnat
du monde féminin 2015 alors on va suivre
aujourd'hui deux parties intéressantes
pour ces matches aller un match aller de
ces quarts de finale
tout d'abord comment donc maria musi
tube va jouer face à koné ou c'est parti
anna maria c'est maria marièrent bouzid
souk al et blanc et elle joue peu quatre
de cinq câbles if3 qu'avait laissé six
des quatre pions prend cavaliers prend
f3 donc ça c'est une variante de type
écossaise avec des quatre très
rapidement c'est pas c'est pas trés
usuels à ce niveau là c'est ça a été ça
a été la mode dans les années 90
kasparov avait un peu mis ça au goût du
jour
il avait mis au goût de jour beaucoup de
choses kasparov puisqu'il avait aussi
mis le d'ambivalence donc là c'est des
variantes un peu anciennes ce type de
vente là qu'ont été réactualisé
relativement récemment quand on parle en
terme d'histoire du jeu d'échecs mais
voilà des médecis c3 consolide le centre
cavaliers cette dame g3 pardon j'ai
trois des scènes pour les noirs tout
ceci doit être très théorique on va pas
commenter ce début fou j'ai deux ans
protègent eux 4 1 avec le fou tout en
préparant enfin le petit rock puis on
prend et on reprend pas tout de suite
pourquoi pas là sans doute pas peur tant
que roi et au centre les noir sans doute
pour s'accrocher à ce pion vont prendre
des risques
petit rebond qui s'y accrochent pas et
voilà qu'à valider deux sas est en prise
deux fois donc même si on protège on va
pouvoir prendre tranquillement
voyez qu'on se presse pas on sort ses
pièces b6 tour aux 1res pas toujours à
reprendre puis entre cavaliers prend
pardon on prend d'abord avocat ce qui
permet de contrôler la casse des 4 une
fois de plus avec la dame dame f5
faut prendre propose un échange de fou à
moins que cavaler ces six possibilités
sans doute ici aussi les noirs aurait pu
peut-être à la place de cavale et c6
tenter un tour des huit thèmes
intéressants attendait 8 qui cloue quand
même un tout petit peu le fou est-ce que
c'est très grave
sans doute pas
manoeuvre possible pour s'en sortir
tranquillement qu'avait laissé six cd
début de partie qui doit être analysée
par les joueuses bien entendu fou prend
apprend et la f4 et 4 ça c'est déjà un
coup responsable parce que là on
affaiblit un la diagonale ici mais bon
on prend un peu d'espacé ici de ce côté
là on contre la fin de cinq années que
le foot recasement a disparu c'est moins
grave mais bon c'est jamais s'est jamais
totalement sans conséquence est quand
même ce genre de manoeuvres faut 6
les trois le pion à deux été attaqué par
le fou et la torah 8 en jouant b3 on
protège pas problème pourquoi pas parce
que h6 mais maintenant que les bleus ont
protégé puis ce cadeau était en prise
les blancs pouvaient jouer la manoeuvre
cavaliers g5 attaque le fou ou un nouvel
fout pas évident il n'y a pas beaucoup
de casa pas rentrer à la maison c'est
pas terrible
qui plus est derrière on pourrait jouer
dès damage 5 voire des fous eux quatre
attaques la dame qui pourrait y avoir
des menaces sur le roi il faut que
l'arrière faut faire attention quand
même donc h si ça évite ces manoeuvres
pas de problème h trois tours à 3 à leur
tour à 3 l'idée c'est qu'on bloque le
pion à deux il peut pas bouger on peut
pas jouer à 4 par exemple et on menace
éventuellement pourquoi pas de doubler
les tours et ont fait pression sur le
tueur à 2 c'est une possibilité
dam des deux ça leur fait pas peur et
enjoint dam des deux on protège une
nouvelle fois à 2 donc même si les noirs
double c'est pas assez pas un problème
alors les noirs commencent à doubler
avec la dame et puis ils vont peut-être
triplé bon jeu qu'on peut aussi triplé
avec les blancs la défense sur a2 b4
décide donc je le coupé 4 sa part un peu
douteux ici est ce ce coup pourquoi
parce que bien sûr on attaque la dame
bon mais à court terme
c'est facile d'enlever la dame et le fou
mais nantes ap / a2 donc ça va faire
quand même
1 2 3 gratuitement on a joué des trois
arrivées de menaces noir aussi bien sûr
ici les cas manoeuvre c'est que bien sûr
les noirs pouvaient prendre le pion b3
et en cas de prise bout s'il ya un qui
tombe en premier on pourrait défendre
ici par c4 c4 est possible
enfin pourquoi pas b4
déjà ça semble un peu tendu la manoeuvre
pour les blancs qui se sont faits un peu
débordé par cette technique alors voyez
c'est le problème aussi de c pour ça il
faudrait réfléchir à deux fois avant de
prendre ces fous qui se replie sur b6
comme ça parce qu'en prenant on permet à
prendre mais qui ramène un pion vers le
centre et qui ouvre la fameuse colonne
bon c'est souvent sans conséquence mais
on voit que souvent on veut pas dire
toujours donc b4 attaque la dame très
bien ondama 4 faut commencer à jouer
précis avec les blancs alors intéressant
le coup suivant des blanchis 4
pas mal très bien vu je pense parce que
finalement bon le sens très bien tenu ah
bon il n'y a pas de problème pour les
blancs au centre même si les noirs sont
tous des huit bons et justement pourquoi
parce que les pièces là là sont quand
même sur le côté pour aller chercher un
pion eh bien on a des pièces un peu un
peu éloigné bon un jour j'ai quatre
éventuellement g5 et pourquoi pas j6m
francs sera pas possible parce que le
fou risque d'être en l'air ou alors on
peut menacer f5 aussi le fou à bouger et
f6 sa protégée par le cavalier ça va
casser le
le roc noir donc en fait qu'est ce qui
se passe quand on attaque sur une aile
on risque de se prendre une attaque
contre le roi ça c'est typique c'est un
grand classique alors tour des huit des
noirs c'est normal active la dernière
pièce on est protégé par le cavalier on
attaque la dame donc on gagne un temps
sur la dame terme f2 pourquoi pas tous
reprends ton et la surprenante du côté
noir
pourquoi pas mais bon vous prend au mot
lu ça paraît curieux parce qu'on pouvait
prendre de la dame
ce qui est en prenant de la dame on
propose un échange de damas où les
blancs auraient pu jouer tour deux
attaques la dame mais il ya un échec
possible
déjà on pas perdre de temps ça m'a l'air
mieux dans ne prend que fou prend bien
plus fous prendre ce que je n'aime pas
trop c'est qu'on peut mettre la tour et
un à un ce qui tout le fou bon mais on
peut se déployer sans doute enjoindre
dame b3 et peut-être il n'y a pas de
danger
peut-être c'est pas sûr pourrez calculer
on va pas tout réduire vous prend à deux
très bien pourquoi pas moi ça me paraît
pas terrible la belle et blanc jouent b5
intéressant ou veulent cavaliers si
lecavalier vient en deux sets
il peut y avoir cavaliers six échecs
puis on prend tout reprend et on voit
bien que au noir commence à avoir des
soucis
bon on considère que les blancs les
noirs pourrait contre-attaquer eux mêmes
puisque on a enlevé la tour on n'a pas
bon on a plus que la dame est le fou
pour protéger ici ou salaire suffisant
ça a l'air suffisant ça peut être payant
une contre attaque mais il faut quand
même avoir le coeur bien accroché pour
jeu de caballos est sachant qu'il ya
cavalière six échecs
puis on prend tout reprend le rock est
cassé la tour et en recettes
c'est pas agréable bon alors b5
le joue cavalier à cette cogneront c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais ceci dit oui val cavaliers
à part cette case il faudra les recettes
risques et cavaliers m6 échec puis on
prend un tour prend qui semble
extrêmement dangereux
donc s'il ya un bain 8 c'est pas
forcément beaucoup mieux et si c'est
beaucoup mieux pourquoi parce que
pourquoi les blancs jouent b5 ça éloigne
encore une pièce regarder un deux trois
pièces et la mi koné ou sur cette
colonne à tout ça pour aller prendre un
petit on a quand même sentiment que le
roi maintenant il est un peu tout seul
la face à trois grosses pièces qui
attendent que ça que ça s'ouvre regardez
boom g5
outch quand ni où on est en difficulté
alors faut savoir quand même que koné
roue avant ce quart de finale elle a
gagné tous ses matches 2 0
c'est à dire qu'elle n'a pas joué un
seul tie break elle a gagné 2 0 de façon
extrêmement efficace à chaque fois là il
se retrouve dans une position un peu
délicate bon c'est que le match aller du
match mais le 2-0 s'éloigner quelques
sortes donc h 30 g5 et a très bien joué
de la part de marien musi tchouk cavale
et prend le craignait tranquille
cavaliers prends ça fait peur
le cal et vise f7 et surtout achètent
parce que bon f7 il ya le foin qui
protège mais f7 connaissait la manoeuvre
d'un mach 4 dans machete matt que font
les noirs ya presque maths parce que roy
et fuite damache huit matches la tour e
empêche en plus le roi noir de tenter
de s'échapper donc la menace elle est
allée extrêmement rapide ici bon sûr
dommage car on peut encore jouer dams et
2 par exemple avec les noirs que le
double intérêt un de contrôler h 7 et 2
d'envisager des tours d2 contre attaquer
sur le roi mais ça marche pas parce que
le fou ici j'ai deux je vais enlever il
ya trop de trop de cases
le foot c'est de regarder quand on va
jouer d'un match 4
si on vient imposer la dame ici en c2
pour contrôler h7 est bien le fou il va
en quatre attaques la dame et on va pas
pouvoir empêcher les blancs d'aller
mater donc là ça a l'air extrêmement
difficile à défendre
alors elle joue sans doute ce qui est un
des rares coups possibles c'est pas le
meilleur c'est chou ici il semblerait
que la seule défense c'était de jouer le
difficile à trouver
tour d un joli l'idée est simple la la
dame peut pas trop partir puisque la
tour étant prises en cas de prise des
blancs je reprends échec puis la dame
ici pourrait envisager de venir par
exemple 25 et l'appareil a plus de match
7 rebonds et blanc pur et centralisée
quand même leurs dames derrière il ya un
met aussi en débutant c'était un couloir
donc en changer six ça a l'air de tenir
quand même ça est ici donc la sai
mobilise un peu les pièces blanches
autour des 1 ça paraît assez logique
comme coup sûr d'un match 4 ben tout
reprend échec et orages ne marche pas
pour continuer à menacer parce que là il
ya plus de matin ça y est la cie la tour
n'est plus là le roi parents et fuite
sur un échec mais il vient cette il n'y
a pas de maths mais peut-être une petite
course contre le roi mais c'est pas sûr
que ça dure longtemps donc la cale epson
qu' il y avait encore possibilité pour
une autre se défendre bon tour des
hommes semblent former non qu'on est un
jouet un coussin
bizarre m6 qui perd qui perd grâce à une
magnifique combinaison des blancs pas
facile à voir
alors on pourrait tenter d'un mach 4 ça
marche pas parce qu'ils me tueraient
pions puis on prend prendre cavaliers
pardon mais il ya très jolie dame des
deux magnifiques en fallait le voir
nationale superbe
pourquoi vous voyez tout de suite si
tout reprend bien entendu
échec et mat un coup
et oui le roi noir est encore dans un
couloir puisque le cavalier ses
classiques contrôler les deux autres
cases et le pion l'empêchent de bouger
voilà les noirs sont matt sous un
magnifique d'un des deux donc voyez ce
coup-là marche pas à cause de cette
variante ici dam des deux alors là il
est noir sont en difficulté là que faire
seul coup un des rares coups c'est de
jouer la tour par exemple en des huit
voire en 1/8 pourquoi bat pour empêcher
le mal du couloir tout simplement
mais c'est déjà dur parce que même si la
tour viande v8
simplement on va jouer fou en d5 les
noirs bien sûr peuvent prendre du fou
alors s'ils prennent pas alors si bien
dans les fuites seimat par le cavage
cette cavale il vient ici
matt & cie vient de l'autre côté ont
ensuite par exemple ici
on peut jouer avec les blancs dames 2
menace note en page 5
d'accord et si ici les noirs prennent le
fou on pourrait être tenté ça ça a l'air
de tenir encore un tout petit peu mais
ça marche pas d'un match 5 échecs au g8
et encore mieux je pensais à damas 7
mais ça marche pas il ya encore dure
toujours le couloir échec et échec et
mat forcé joli hein donc là oui c'est
chaud quoi alors elle joue encore touré
fuite et l'a semble-t-il yahia matt
forcé regardez toujours la même variante
fou échec alors là à noter que la vraie
ne convient de voir aussi les noirs ne
prennent pas d'âme de marche pas pour
menacer fait ça si ça marche quand même
mais pas pour la même raison puisqu'à
pas de mal du couloir on n'y a pas
d'échec là parce que la tour est en
fuite
bon alors là les noirs pourraient
prendre le fou ou alors l'autre couquet
l'a pas fait mais qu'on va voir ce
serait de jouer 3 h 8 parce que la s qui
amat alors on tente la même variante
dans le 2 ça marche parce que si les
noirs prennent le fou dame échec roi g8
est maintenant de damas sept matchs
puisque la tour ici en fuite empêche le
roi noir de partir et le cavalier en
peuvent toujours si on prend le cavalier
c'est ma direct puisque le fou contrôle
j'évite voyez c'est chaud donc pour
éviter ça surfe ou échec elle prend du
fou très bien dans mes chèques ensuite
dames et c'est très joli
magnifique ce dernier coup voilà il ya
tous les thèmes lui a fait tous les
thèmes la musique zouk dans cette partie
à un pico nehru l'apport est là elle n'a
rien vu venir ces abandons là que là il
ya rien à faire un parce que là la
menace les doubles c'est de faire d'un
match 5 échecs dames 1 h 7
matt est aussi dame prend tour et si les
noirs prennent bien entendu qui est
l'autre seul coup possible si simplement
touré cheikh fuite
et encore une fois échec et mat du
couloir
incroyable ouais donc plié en 29 coup un
pico nehru favorite du tournoi gagné
tous ses matches 2-0 en fait 9 pouces
fait mater un quart de finale du
championnat du monde 1 donc qu'est ce
qui s'est passé est bien un probablement
on pourrait dire que c'est toute cette
manoeuvre d'aller chercher sur le côté
là qui qui a l'air bon bon on va prendre
le pion mais qui a sous-estimé la contre
attaque blanche et les noirs n'ont pas
vu venir et puis surtout il avait plus
qu'une suite pour faire nul et ils l'ont
ratée après ici donc on avait vu d'un
rêve de tour points à 2 tours prend à
deux francs à deux baies 5 qui cavaliers
à 7 semblait possible encore j'essaie
donc à chaud que la vallée prend m6 l'un
des deux s'est déjà fait c'est déjà
perdu c'était ici qu'à les gsm voilà
c'est là que les noirs ont raté le
possible tour d un voile à tour d un
permettez sans doute sans doute
d'annuler mais semblerait que les blancs
quand même un peu d'attaqués a toujours
sa part hier simple mais ça a l'air de
tenir quand même là bon par exemple que
faire avec les blancs ici c'est pas
évident déjà si je prends en dame prend
un échec
imaginons il n'y a pas trop de choix en
fait mais sinon tout reprend simplement
dame prend échec
autre variante il ya un bond par exemple
roi
parce que probablement
hélas les noirs ce que les noirs
pourraient prendre ici attention mais
alors c'est pourquoi il ya quand même
des choses dit encore il ya encore des
petites choses et encore des petites
choses encore du jeu pour les blancs
mais c'est moins dangereux puisque a pas
la tour on l'a vu que la tour était
utile pour faire plein match
et là c'est moins clair disant voilà ce
que même si j'arrive à faire un échec en
âge sept jeux par alors c'est sûr je me
prends en échec à un jeu suit le plonger
septembre si j'arrive à faire ça mais
bon alors à noter que ces deux pièces on
cogne toujours hors jeu voyait donc le
danger dans cette partie illustre et
même en championnat du monde
le fait d'avoir des pièces tout comme ça
sur une rangée est très loin du de
l'action très loin du centre et le très
loin du roi c'est pas une bonne idée
donc qu'au nez rouge avait battu voilà
alors on va voir maintenant l'autre
partie intéressante de la journée
c'est la partie qui opposait pogonat
face à soues zaho donc pour une idée on
la connaît on l'a suivi dans le match
face à marie on a suivi quatre parties
puisque ça s'est joué au tie break après
les deux parties langues
on a eu droit à un tie-break aussi donc
là dans cette partie pogo nina façade
souza au donc on y va c'est parti avec
up et 4,46 s'éclate c'est ce qu'elle
joue un pogo nina et jouer des quatre à
chaque fois plus 6 g iii
des cinq classes 3 donc c'est classique
ça ressemble a encore une fois une
espèce de catalan toujours pareil on a
joué le fond j'ai deux dans ce type de
variantes là où les noirs jouent dans
une structure de type classique sok-yong
dames les blancs jouent un g3 transpose
dans une autre type de variantes cette
fameuse catalan up mari avait tendance à
jouer on l'a vu ces 6 et là c'est pas
pareil hein souza au et joue pas ça elle
le prend en c4 dame ces deux ont contre
attaque le pion à noter qu'ici le coup
b5 serait très certainement puni c'est
pas c'est pas une super idée de ce genre
de coups puisqu'on joue par exemple à
quatre ça détruit la structure si je
joue à 6 apprend et si je joue c'est 6
regardez il se passe à prendre mais 5 et
sur ses preuves et 5,15 ouverture
classique up cavaliers ou 5 ou cavalli
g5 c'est encore plus précis sans doute
et hop attaque sur wii c'est encore
mieux que je saigne parce que ça attaque
la tour et en plus si le seul coup qui
empêche le fou d'attaquer la tour c'est
de jouer le cavalier par exemple en d5
mais dans ce cas là regardez il ya aussi
un match alors je peux jouer à 6 ici le
cavalier bouge je peux jouer cavalier et
des singles mais je prends la tour bien
entendu est maintenant sûr pions prendre
j'ai le choix je peut soit prendre le
pion de g5 soit prendre le pion à cette
bon c'est une horreur donc dépenser de
dams et 2 attention ce type de pions si
vous protéger avec un point g 2 c'est
pas une bonne idée mais souvent mais
même dans le camp bilham attention il ya
des pièges même quand le fou va pas
enlever deux en essayant de protéger
on se prend des dames f3 à la fin qui
vont gober la tournée faites attention à
ça à 6
là on prépare b 5 mai à 4
impossible puisqu'il y aurait à prendre
s'éprend et tout reprend tour c'est pas
une bonne idée donc fou 17 noeuds la
part nous avons je vous avoue dans prend
maintenant ça y est c'est leur fou ces
six très bien le fou par cette manoeuvre
vient s'opposer aux fous j'ai 2 1
c'est bien ça permet de calmer le jeu
tous les cercles h6 voilà fou prend
parce que si on vous faisait scène
permettant à m6 pour revenir avec le fou
parce que là on peut pas les en faire on
peut aller h 40 g 5 et on va perdre une
pièce contre deux pions et je pense que
c'est pas très très bon parce que les
noirs vont se défendre assez facilement
donc la foux prend fou prend il a
simplement kabylie c3 voilà on regardait
harmonieux et les blancs sont bien
développés mais les noirs aussi la
position est équilibrée à la foux prends
ça c'est étonnant puisqu'il ya après il
ya fou prend cavaliers afu prend ici qui
vise 17
donc en cas de prise en d4 il ya
bessette qui tombe mais un sous-homme le
fait quand même d'un prend b4 elle ne
fait pas ici elle fait donc après les
change ici donc elle te protège 17 et d4
est attaqué elle aurait pu quand même
prendre des quatrains peut-être c'est
possible aussi d'en prendre des quatre
ça a l'air bon ce que là je prends
probablement des quatre je peux aussi
tenté d'aller prendre ces sept
c'est possible on peut aussi aller
prendre ces sept qu'avait laissé six
proposant
le fou prennent mais on va prendre un
bessette a donné des pions on a fini son
développement rapidement on va mettre le
kava y en a 5 et puis il ya des trous
ici le fait qu'on ait joué à 4 fait que
les petites roues donc le jeu des noirs
doit être facile après un donc voilà
alors c63 très solide à noter regardez
comme c'est harmonieux les pions sur ce
clanwar et en à l'oeuf ou de cases
blanches ça c'est bien puisque les pions
font le travail du fou qui n'est plus là
le foot cases noires il remplacé par les
pions donc fouet pions sont très
complémentaires à cinq
voilà à 5 évite b4 parce que là les
blancs auraient joué b4 avec la fameuse
attaque de minorités c'est là qu'on sait
quoi la tacc de minorités sergic
d'options contre 3 je suis en minorité
mais justement ça me permet de
d'attaquer cette chaîne de pions et
d'avoir à la fin un pur tout seul a
découvert que je vais essayer de gober
voilà c'est classique un an ce dans ce
type d'ouverture alors pas 5 dans b3 vi
v cet homme ses sept tours à saint
laurent chesnais tour à 6,1
développement original tour à 6 on sort
par le cavalier par 17 et centraliser
les tours on joue plutôt tour b6
pourquoi pas peut-être que les noirs
veulent venir en b6 avec la tour et oui
peut-être faire pression sur cette
petite colombe et là en passant devant
le pion profité du fait que
effectivement cette petite structure
blanche allait pas terrible la case bk
très faible un peu plus l'attaqué avec
un pion avec les blancs donc on peut y
installer une tour on peut y installer
éventuellement le fou pour revenir ici
cette es4
peut-être que les noirs veulent jouer
aussi tourbe et 6 après après avoir fini
la tour en b 6 la dame joue ont fait
cavaliers à 6 calais b 4 avec un très
beau caillou b4 aussi ça a l'air bon
pour les noirs de ce côté là voyez les
blancs pas comment ils n'ont pas essayé
de percuter au centre ils ont laissé un
peu les noirs bien se développer
tranquillement les dames et profiter de
leurs petites faiblesses
bon rien de grave un camp pour elle d un
ton des 8 ou g2 d'un v6 adam b6 est bon
pourquoi pas
propose un échange de d'am dam à deux
tours à huit
alors ça et donc le plan finalement ne
le fait pas
c'était de la provoc c'était pour mettre
la dame en fait apparemment cavaliers ou
quatre fausses est à noter qu'un set ce
fou contre wall a une fois de plus la
carte b4 bon cavalier d2 on vient en d2
on peut venir en c4 attaque la dame
pourquoi pas vise la case de seine pour
lui mettre un cavalier ça peut être bien
mais qu'avaient les 17
donc si je viens en ckd j'attaque la
dame et la case e5 est contrôlé par le
cas les cavaliers adverse h4 on glane de
l'espace tranquille pas de risque grave
pour l'instant où b4 le fou très bien
placé protégé par un pion petite
pression sur le cavalier est ce que
c'est grave je sais pas je pense pas ce
qu'il vaut mieux changer alors ce fou ou
est ce qu'il est bon pas bon sur le
tient compte du pion à 5 qu'ils soient
même couleur que fout c'est sûr que bon
il est plutôt défensive dans ce cas là
mais les pions sur sur noir mais c'est
très solide le pion f2 qu'est la base
des chaînes de pure ans pour aller
chercher celui-là va fort se lever tous
donc cavalier aux 4 bon juste pour
prendre de l'espace se positionner au
centre gabrielle 6 ça c'est étonnant
propose de casser de sa propre sûre que
de pur bon pourquoi pas car elle le fait
pour une île à qui on prend après
cavaliers préemption prend qui est mieux
ici
or c'est difficile à juger ça c'est
quand même pas bon c'est sûr face au roi
et on a des fous de couleurs opposées
alors il faut de couleurs posées quand
il reste encore des pièces comme ça avec
un faible c'est bon pour l'attak
encore faut-il arriver à l'acte iv alors
peut-être parfait fc 4 visée ces
diagonales et puis essayer peut-être de
faire une rupture plus tard à part de sa
part à partir de f4 f5 est visé c'est
des modèles mais mais on risque
d'affaiblir nos pions qui sont sur cases
noires donc attention c'est dangereux
aussi dame ses cadres les fuites et on
revient aux deux plutôt que d'être en a
deux on vient à eux deux et puis il ya
eu deux bons c'est vrai qu'on peut aller
chatouiller un peu le roi adverse 1 qui
est quand même qui sait créer des trous
tout seul tour 17
pour ces quatre
t'auras des huit double tour finalement
au centre voyez les manoeuvres ont été
lentes mais bon les noirs ont fini par
se développer de façon quasiment presque
classique un tour d'essai un bon
pression sur cette colonne alors ça bute
contre mur ça c'est un mur pour rien
faire contre ça puis on voit pas même si
le roi semble faible c'est difficile
parce que ses deux pions sont
extrêmement bien défendus par le fou on
peut pas l'attaquer avec notre propre
fou donc si on voulait faire quelque
chose soit il faut s'affaiblir g4 g5
soit il faut donner une qualité
alors bon il faut y réfléchir à deux
fois faisait 7
on n'est pas près d'y arriver belle le
fait quand même beaucoup nina bon un peu
un peu tendu le g4 ici bas pourquoi pas
bon ça passe ça paraît pas mauvais on
veut profiter d'un roi noir un peu en
l'air mais on risque d'affaiblir son
trois pros - ça c'est toujours le
problème aux 5
voilà c'est une vraie menace un pion
prend des quatre et on gagne un pion
parce qu'il ya du matériel donc il faut
prendre on n'a pas le choix des
pronostics et la tour d2 et vais les
jouer
deux tours la dame est attaqué on est
sur la deuxième belle manoeuvre des
noirs tout ça est un peu lent mais ça a
l'air de bien fonctionner dan f3
attention la menace pions principe six
semaines on gagne un pion net et
simplement on couvre la deuxième par
tour ces deux tomes b3
c'est pénible 1 c'est pénible impression
latour menace de prendre envoyée si les
blancs prennent ici en d2 reprendre la
tour la tour c quatre et sept attaques
et gilles pression sur la deuxième
rangée le tombé 2 va tomber il faut
trouver un coup c'est pas simple à
trouver un bon coup pour coup nina
tranquille fallait le voir dames 4 bien
très jolie en cas de prix tout soutient
la dame 400 ou pas de problème allez
imprenable et centralisée c'est très
bien c'est un très bon coup en france et
2 et là un tour france et de tranquille
tour des trois dont deux trois pourquoi
ben et sa coupe la protection de la tour
voilà tout simplement en d3 le fait pas
grand chose sauf que ben il faut faire
quelque chose avec cette tour qu'est ce
qu'on fait ben on fait rien dame c4 bien
jouer prise prise
et là regardez très jolies manoeuvres de
zaho de souza au fouet fuite
ça a l'air de rien mais vous allez voir
ce qui va se passer mais blanc jouent
tous ses tours ses trois proposé un
échange de tours pas facile de trouver
autre chose
tours d2 on est sur la deuxième on
attaque et la tombe et 3 à l'air
intéressant puisqu'on attaque bessette
bien sûr mais là on avait joué fouet
fuite
regardez très joli fond b4 et là
regardez c'est tour à la plus de cases
c'est énorme à 3 c3 détroit tout est
pris bon ça pas l'air très très grave
regarder parce qu'il ya encore une
défense mois les foules couleurs
opposées maintenant ça devient c'est
difficile quand même de faire pression
de façon directe fouet 4 voilà fouet 4
et j'ai la case d3 pour la tour mais
attention parce qu'il ya eu il y avait
une vraie menace ces cinq c4 et on perd
une tour donc d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui
se passe maintenant sur ces 5 c'est
parce qu'on fait les noirs mais c'est
intéressant menace c'est qu'elles
gagnent autour toujours puisque la case
d3 est prise
sa force autour des 3 et d'entreprendre
le pion b2 alors pas facile analyse est
quand même cette position mais ça ça a
l'air bon quand même très bon pour les
noirs ce pion ne rêve que d'une chose
c'est d'avancer en plus la casse ces
deux qui est pas une case de faire dame
mais les contrôles et déjà par la tour
ça va ça va être très très fort bon
les fous de couleurs opposées sont aussi
un facteur annulant parce que si je mets
une tour ans et 7 le fou contrôle c2 la
tour aussi jamais les noirs pourront
pousser les pions
voilà et le pion de behcet risque de
tomber ces mêmes paris ce que c'est qui
va tomber la main probablement et en
plus je peux attention je peux aussi
créé des menaces contre le roi parce que
maintenant que j'ai mes pièces ici
toujours un peu la même idée comme la
première partie l'europe seulement il
n'y a pas de vraie menace contre le roi
mais il bon c'est pas un critère absolu
ce pion passé parce que foot couleurs
reposer je contrôle c2 je peux venir à
ces sept
en plus je serai sur la 7ème donc ça
risque de compenser mais c'est quand
même c'est quand même pénible
je pense que cette position était
préférable à ce qu a joué les noix leur
tour d un échec moi j'ai deux tours 1
et voilà gagne le point 4 elle préfère
gagner le point à 4 que le pion b2 alors
ça peut-être parce que le plan b 2 et
sur noir donc se dit peut-être qu'avec
le foot cases noires à l'heure actuelle
prendre plus facilement que le pion là
qui peut être protégé par le fou c'est
possible pourquoi pas tourné trois et on
prend voilà tout est mal placée
puisqu'elle est un peu bloqué par son
fou donc simplement ici les noirs les
blancs jouent au roi f3 voilà je me
rapproche du centre j'active mes pièces
on n'est pas trop trop inquiet avec les
blancs jouent on allait [ __ ] que le
reposer encore une fois c'est un facteur
annulant beaucoup de positions mais tant
que les tours sont là c'est pas clair
faut ensuite tombée trois ans revient en
b3 parce qu'on veut empêcher le très
fort tour b4 là en cas de tourbe et crac
sans doute on échange
p4 on revient autour des 3 en espérant
répété dix ans qui veulent annuler veut
bien parce que c'est vrai que la bombe
et j'ai quand même faisons un petit
bilan j'ai quand même un pion de moins
si vous comptez bien pas très très grave
au final le fou mais c'est dans cette
finale là mais c'est quand même un
facteur ou c'est les noirs qui joue pour
le game pas les blancs donc tour à 2
fait pression sur le pion b2o mais les
blancs contre attaque sur 17
ce qui paraît normal b6 les noirs
préfèrent garder leurs pions de façon à
ce qu'ils restent liés voilà ils sont
liés ses pions elles préfèrent ils
savent très bien que pour essayer de
gagner ce type de finale il vaut mieux
pas avoir des pions isolé vaut mieux
avoir des pions liés c'est vrai que des
pions lié contrefout même de couleur
opposée
ça gagne c'est très fort les pions lié
voilà donc c'est ça l'idée est de ce
type de coup b3 alors là on joue b3 pour
avoir le pion sur la case du fou après
fou prend des cinq ans contrôle b3 n'y a
pas de problème là les noirs jouent
fouen qui est logique le pion f2 est
perdu et blanc ne peuvent pas le
protéger
encore une fois c'est pas très grave
même si ça peut l'assemblée ça ne l'est
pas fou prend ses 6 pour preuve de
l'échec est là on voit là ça permet de
monter le roi henri iv
voilà donc on a pris le pion aux 6
maintenant il y en a c'est qu'ils
emprise bon c'est pas facile de défendre
tout ça à [ __ ] qu'il repose et en plus
on à la 37e le pion à vii et solutions
classe blanche donc surtout des cinq ce
ne sera pas facile de le défendre ses
pions peuvent s'échanger bon on n'a pas
trop peur faut pas oublier qu'à la fin
si le foot sacrifie contre le pion touré
fou contre tours la plupart du temps
c'est nul et mais attention attention
qu'on me l'a dit plusieurs fois c'est
pas facile à défendre et dans certains
cas dans beaucoup de cas en fait c'est
gagnant quand même mais on peut quand
même sauvé une partie avec la tour
contre touré fou si on sait bien jouer
la finale n'y a pas de problème ça peut
faire nul si la position de départ n'est
pas une déposition
justement de gain théorique parce qu'il
ya certaines positions quand on est en
fait quand on est proche du bord tout
simplement sur le trop proche du bord
touré fou contre tours si on est en
défense il ya des gains forcé pour
l'adversaire donc il faut éviter torres
6 tf6 à noter que la tour protéger f7
ici on pose la question aux fous et on
protège à la fois h6 et b6 ou des scènes
pression maximale sur f7 sa immobilise
la tour si la tour bouge f7 tombe et là
les noirs mais prennent autre pion donc
1 2 3 4 5 1 de 3,2 kg en plus bon mais
aucun pour le passé déjà ça c'est un bon
point
après si la tour bouge on paierait vii
donc qu'ils ont de plus c'est déjà un
peu douteux s'il a pu avancer la tour
jeudi ressort de cette colonne f et on
voit mal avec les noirs comment
progresser si le noire s'échappe aussi
on va prendre f7 si on bouge ses pions
la tour va aller sans doute le client
par exemple baissé à 4 pions prend puis
on prend un tour là et c'est fini il est
cueilli ses pions et a plus que trois
pions contre 2 du même côté avait des
poutres qui leur posaient pour la gagne
et c'est là encore une fois et ça va pas
être simple et en plus le plus
inquiétant prise tout simplement on va
prendre on l'a trouvé pas vraiment à qui
elle fout mais bon faut faire quelque
chose aussi roi g7 est là pourquoi pas
où j'ai trois mois j'ai six tranquille
les noirs avancent alors ce qu'ils
aimeraient bien faire les noirs bien
entendu c'est gober ce pion g4 ça leur
crème puis ont passé au moins voilà si
l'on inclut ont passé c'est pas tout à
fait la même parce que même dans les cas
de fou de couleurs opposées un pion
passer par une si on arrive à le mettre
jusqu'à 1h de il faut qu'une pièce s'en
occupe en permanence
donc pendant ce temps là les mains
libres pour aller de l'autre côté et
faire autre chose tour des cinq des six
top-5
alors c'est un coup responsable on
propose de rentrer dans une finale de
pions avec des fous de couleur opposée
où on a un seul pion de -2 3 4 22 3
et ce faisant le problème de jouer tour
f cell dans cette position c'est que
après ce que joue d'ailleurs les noirs
tout reprend si on prend un échec on
réussisse et bien les noms rendus ont
passé c'est ce qu'on disait voilà si on
pouvait s'en crée un ce serait pas mal
bon avec ou sans les tours on va le
pousser ses pions
alors wade sainte anne en faire quelque
chose tous essayent l'avantagent de
jouer ce coup c'est 5 c'est qu'il est
protégé par b6 donc il ya pas de
problème si on l'avait mis ans et 7
avril on aurait continué par foudroie c6
ou des huit roi 17 ou valve fou ci vient
11,7 et bien cette fois là non ça marche
en fait on peut annoncer celle qui a pas
de problème ont pu peut-être c'est aussi
4 pour les blancs bombés 5 difficile à
paris mais est-ce que c'est grave en
général dans les finales de roi il faut
savoir que celui qui a le plus le plus
loin qu'ils gagnent parce que le temps
que le roi prenne celui qui est loin
l'autre roi prend celui qui est prêt et
à la fin il va gober les pions qui sont
donc de l'autre côté alors que lui le
temps qu'ils reviennent c'est mort
l'idée générale c'est celle là bon mais
ce qu'ils vont en finale le roi est vrai
dans presque toutes les autres finales
c'est bon et puis finale de pièces
légères notamment de cavaliers et aussi
de fou ça peut être le cas si en plus le
pion pas s'est éloigné c'est pénible n'y
a pas plus éloignés comme pion h ou un
pion à l'occurrence ici on peut pas
aller plus loin donc c'est très éloigné
donc là
jouer le plan souza au rocher cinq mois
j'ai 5
bon ça évite échec et puis on va voir
son idée après alors à noter que scène
tout de suite marche pas parce qu'il ya
simplement le pion qu'ils ont prises
foot est roi protège d'abord pour godina
protéger cinq ans peut-être que les
noirs voulait jouer même si si si c'est
possible mais eux scène quand même puis
on prend roi prend et puis j'ai un pion
passez moi aussi mais il est moins loin
que celui là bon et là j'ai quand même
deux pions contre eux aussi bon ces
finales de coups le foot couleurs
opposées mais attention parce que plus
les pions sont éloignés plus c'est
difficile à défendre
c'est d'autant plus facile à défendre
finale de foot couleurs opposées que les
pions sont tous groupés au même endroit
six wallonie c'est plus dur de contrôler
les deux côtés on y arrive même parfois
même souvent un mais c'est quand même le
cas qui peut donner des chances
alors attention h5 ça y est on y va ces
partis ont eu cinq ou six puits ont
passé qui ont passé au f4 or la coupe
étonnant alors l'idée doit être quatre à
mon avis c'est de rendre difficile le
food et cinq bien on peut jouer tous des
st louis et sur geof ou des scènes on
pourra plus jouer au cices facilement
puisque pions prend puis on prend le roi
attaque le fou alors si c'est possible
déclaration
si on joue food est simple qu'est ce qui
se passe ici regardons un peu fou des
cinq jours par exemple h 4 au 6 mai puis
on prend puis on prend
h3 alors l'idée de pousser le pion
jusqu'au bout c'est d'immobiliser se
font au maximum à la défense de hache un
salaire de tenir quand même on par
exemple le tien typiquement on peut
jouer tout achat ou d'attentes puis on
n'a pas grand chose d'autres on peut pas
jouer le roi c'est ça le problème
si on jouait le rôle faire le fou donc
la fois chain maintenant h 2 le fou
contrôle bien
donc quand les blancs pousseront le set
même si le roi protège on peut prendre
le roi prend et si on bouge les piaules
alors ouanna peut pas aller chercher le
pion il n'a pas le temps il est trop
loin et se fout bay va être perdue
puisque roy g3 wave 2 juin on va le
gagner
donc si et apprécie les blancs sont
obligés de rester parce que la manoeuvre
cette marche pas puisque
la fin ses pions passé vont gagner et
bien avec le roi noir j'ai tout le temps
de revenir de l'autre côté
donc la white c'est déjà un problème
donc au f4 voilà c'est c'est pour viser
contre se fout des cinq ça perd du temps
et il est bien placé aussi pour venir en
g3 wave ii etc
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
peut-être que dans cette position est
déjà mal quoi parce qu'en fait on peut
pas avec les blancs venir avec le roi on
a peut-être à il faudrait mettre le roi
de ce côté en fait d'autant que c'est
très certainement ça parce que ici
regardez le pion pour faire dame ces
cases blanches ornées lé foot cases
noires donc imaginons qu'on enlève
toutes les pièces là plus que roi fou et
pions et le roi arrive là c'est nul faut
le savoir on peut pas gagner avec le fou
du de la mauvaise case pour gagner avec
un pion à ou h avec un fou il faut que
ce pion sur de la couleur du fou donc le
bon pion pour les noirs c'est celui là
donc celui là on peut se sacrifier
contre c'est à dire on peut donner le
fou contre ce pion on donnait on vous
l'a puis même si les noirs font des
grandes manoeuvres et tout à la fin
quand il pousse le plus on prend et donc
le roi arrive à aller à chose ce pion
est neutralisée même si les noirs
gardent leur fou et le problème que mes
souza ou ici en évidence en juin cette
manoeuvre de roy qui paraît curieuse 3g
st croix c'est qu'en fait elle coupe
là le passage au roi blanc il peut pas
venir et c'est peut-être ce les blancs
ont sous-estimé dans cette finale de
5,24 aussi ce magnifique puis on prend
puis on prend bon c'est bien ça traîne
contre auch ans et on va voir que ça va
pas être possible h 4 ans et 6 h 3
tous éclater si je pensais déjà perdu un
match de fou des scènes quand même ouf
on protège et 3 on va venir en deux on
va venir en juin et on va faire dame que
font les blancs à 17
bref deux os est fou prend roi prend et
attention maintenant faut pas se tromper
faut pas jouer ou alger 1
on l'aurait fait s'il est blanc n'avait
rien fait mais là les blancs sont allés
prendre le plan qu'est ce qu'on avait
dit ses deux pions là ils vont plus vite
que le roi il n'a pas le temps d'aller
les chercher
et oui les cinq ans n'e 6 à 4 terminé et
oui parce que là que font les blancs bas
il faut prendre n'a pas trop le choix
qu'ils ont pris en plus on prend bon
admettons qu'on vienne avec le roi à
trois et vous dites oui le fou contrôle
oui mais il peut pas contrôler les deux
c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure dans les finales de comme ça de
fouet notamment de foot que leur poser
si les pions de son numéro un droit
c'est très très souvent nul mais voyez
que les cas de gain comme ça c'est voilà
quand les pions sont éloignés on n'a pas
ce que c'est difficile scala et puis en
plus son nom qu'on a le droit qu'a pas
pu venir en défense du mauvais pions
blancs bombés pions c'était celui-là est
celui là il aurait fallu que le fou
contrôle plutôt celui là et pas celui là
voilà donc là ça s'est joué avec ce coup
très certainement donc vainqueur de ce
match aller 1
sunao et voyant revoyons là l'erreur
probablement ce couteau rêve 5 déjà est
un peu du tout alors on n'est pas pressé
d'échanger les tours le plan de gains
c'est c'est de créer un pion passé pour
les noirs etc
bon alors on peut jouer par exemple
fouet deux pour protéger car s'il est
attaqué mais pour l'instant il n'est
même pas attaquer donc pourquoi ce
pourquoi se presser quoi pu attendre
tranquillement et peut-être il faut
absolument protéger car il faut que les
noirs démontre que c'est à eux de
démontrer qu'ils peuvent se créer un
pion passé c'est pas au blanc a essayé
de forcer un passage en finale
donc voilà c'est
c'est quand même 7 cette finale encore
une fois on a eu beaucoup de finale
comme ça des erreurs stratégiques mais
évidemment il faut savoir bien jouer
mais finalement ce n'est pas facile mais
à ceci dit c'est vrai c'est clair alors
donc quarts de finale vainqueurs
eh ben on l'a vu on va voir ici tout de
suite
voilà le tableau donc là ici évidemment
pendant la commentaires je n'ai pas le
résultat pour garder l'intérêt si vous
n'avez pas suivi les résultats ailleurs
donc ici conejo a perdu donc la première
soeur musi tchouk est en position
favorable maintenant pour tenter de se
qualifier bon ceci dit alors ah les
noirs contre les blancs elle est très
forte
bon mais les jeunes qu'on ait enfin
music you qu'encore et peut-être qu'elle
est soussou classé mcc le problème et
encore quand on a quand on est quand on
a des jeunes en face évidemment c'est
qu'ils peuvent très souvent être
sous-évalué parce qu'ils sont en
progression
natalia pogo nina face à hawk souza ou a
marqué avec les noirs ça semble mal
partie pour natalia pour une loi qui de
plus est sans doute fatigué de son match
face à marie ce débat qui a été comme on
l'a vu extrêmement éprouvant ça s'est
joué à très peu de choses y compris dans
la dernière partie mari pouvait revenir
on l'a vu donc c'est peut-être la
fatigue aussi qui l'emportent
ça peut jouer contiendra ming a fait nul
avec les blancs donc là ils vont tout
est encore possible face à donc à la
deuxième soeur zouk et enfin donc ici et
bien
ce quatrième match
donc à rica a fait nul face à haras bits
des donc
là des matches qui restent extrêmement
ouvert donc c'est très intéressant la
suite bon peut-être à part ce match
puisque la favorite l'a emporté bon ça
risque d'être extrêmement dur pour
natalia pogonat mais elle a depuis connu
on va tout faire pour gagner avec les
blancs donc ça va ça va être chaud et
ses deux autres matchs bond à une nul
leur permet de continuer à jouer donc
bon c'est peut-être moins entendu le
match le plus tendu en match retour ça
sera très certainement celui là qu'il
faudra suivre de près voilà merci de
m'avoir suivi pour match aller de ces
quarts de finale championnat du monde
2015 sur des gonades tv et je vous dis à
une prochaine fois
au revoir